>> All right, so, so how does this work, Charles? How do you do single link
clustering? Again, assuming the distances are distances in
the plane, just because it makes it easy.
>> Right. So you just keep finding the
clusters that are closest, and you defined it as
where the, the two closest points in two clusters
are what makes them, is what defines their distance.
>> Mm.
>> And so if I look at this, if you
look at, look at the big outer circle. you'll, you'll notice
that each of, you start with any one of those
points and it's always going to be closer to one of
its neighbors on the circle than to, say, one of
those four points in the middle of the circle. Right?
>> They're close to each other.
>> If we start doing mergings, it, it ought
to look something like this, right? Where we've got,
I don't know. [SOUND] Maybe. [SOUND] But little by
little it's going to be linking these things up.
>> Mm-hm. And that's the key thing there that you were drawing
before that the bridge between the two big circles, every point there is
always going to be closer to one of the points on the outer
circle clusters than it's ever going to be. To anything else. And so,
you're going to end up making, one big cluster,
out of the outer shell. Which is kind of weird.
>> It is a little bit weird. You get these kind of stringy
clusters because two things are close to each other if they're close anywhere.
>> Right.
>> So, I don't know. To my eye, the best one is
the bottom right. But it wouldn't do that because k equals 2.
>> Right.
>> So to my, for what's, for what's left,
I guess I like the upper right. But that's
not what single lane clustering would do. It would actually kind of
walk around the circle and link things up. Like in the lower left.